hey guys Jason Silva here to tell you
about an amazingly inspiring initiative
called call for code now call for code
is an initiative from IBM in partnership
with the David Clarke cause the United
Nations Human Rights office and the
American Red Cross call for code is
inviting software developers and data
scientists to come up with software
solutions to come up with innovative
apps to help mitigate some of the tragic
effects of natural disasters such as
loss of life and loss of property now
obviously we can't stop natural
disasters from happening but we can
deploy our imagination and our
technology and our innovation again to
help mitigate some of their effects the
winning team will get two hundred
thousand dollars in IBM we'll work with
the top three software solutions to help
implement them across the world so this
is amazing guys
again visit call for code org to get
involved today tell your friends all the
best